[Musique]
bienvenue dans pôle it mag spécial
municipal aujourd'hui on va parler
éducation nationale et chèque de
l'éducation prioritaire en france une
préoccupation récurrente pour les
français tant du côté des parents
d'élèves que des enseignants on en parle
avec nos invités sur ce plateau line
numa bocage professeur des universités
spécialiste de l'éducation face avoue
grégory touiza du secret de co
secrétaire départemental du syndicat
snes fsu en seine saint denis et nicolas
vidal directeur de publication de putsch
médias merci à tous d'être là ce soir
pour ce débat en pleine crise sociale
contre la réforme du bac et des
retraites le ministère de l'éducation
nationale a envoyé mardi aux 850 mille
enseignants de france
un questionnaire sur le ressenti de leur
métier une enquête en ligne dont les
résultats seront dévoilés lors d'une
grande conférence internationale
intitulée professeur du 21e siècle ce
sera fin mars à l'unesco
l'occasion pour nous de faire le bilan
de l'éducation prioritaire 40 ans après
sa mise en place le gouvernement veut
réformer ce système qui coûte cher et
qui coûte cher par rapport au peu de
résultats obtenus
vous voyez ce reportage en
seine-saint-denis de solenn gaudin
lionel girard et simon vers briand et on
en parle après
m
professeurs non remplacés insalubrité
des locaux violences à l'école en seine
saint denis les enseignants tirent la
sonnette d'alarmé
il souligne un manque criant de moyens
dans le 93 on a des structures qui sont
complètement délabré avec des mairies
qui n'auraient pas rien sans parler des
as de de l'amiante qui sont dans les
écoles certaines mairies fournissent par
enseignant 25 je donne un exemple 25
euros pour l'année par élève
on a une photocopie par élève par jour
s'ils n'ont pas de manuels et si on doit
faire une photocopie par jour par élève
on se retrouve à avoir encore plus de
difficultés ont de plus en plus on est
nivelé vers le bas donc les classes ne
cesse d'augmenter on en avait parlé des
cp à 12
on commence à être un nouveau à des cpa
14 on va passer bientôt dcp 15 16 et
puis on sait qu'on va repasser à des cp
avec dit classe normale à 25 26 élèves
on a beau entendre le le ministre de
l'éducation nationale nous dire qu'il va
mettre davantage de moyens dans le 93
pour l'instant on n'en voit pas alors
face au manque de moyens
les enseignants baisse les bras 37 5%
des professeurs des écoles primaires
reste moins de deux ans dans leur
établissement
c'est 10 % de plus que dans les autres
territoires
un chiffre qui passe à 50 % dans les
collèges et lycées pour un tiers en
moyenne nationale selon le rapport
cornut-gentille de mai 2018 pour
l'égalité en seine-saint-denis et une
situation marquée par des drames
en septembre dernier la directrice d'une
école maternelle de pantin s'est suicidé
dans le hall de son établissement
christine renom avait envoyé plusieurs
courriers au ministère de l'éducation
nationale décriant le manque d'outils et
un sentiment d'abandon
en octobre c'est un jeune de 15 ans qui
a été poignardé en plein cours de sport
lille à cinq mois après rien n'a changé
du côté des parents d'élèves c'est la
consternation
ok oui malheureusement en a connu sa
première connexion drame en septembre
effectivement lorsqu'il a été assassiné
clairement on a quand même identifié qui
avait quand même des gros soucis de
l'interaction entre entre les groupes de
plusieurs villes et que les moyens
supplémentaires et que vraiment
nécessaire donc l'éducation à 100 a pris
des engagements à ce moment là et là les
moyens on est tombé dans l'établissement
mais les parents viennent même 10h30 36
en mai mais où sont les moyens dont vous
aviez promu pour que les choses
s'améliorent à ccc et cure en prenant en
france c'est pas bon de créer des
conditions aussi la violence parce que
c'est ce qui se passe en définitive des
conditions d'enseignement qui se
répercute directement sur les résultats
des élèves en 2019
trois candidats sur quatre ont obtenu
leur baccalauréat en seine-saint-denis
contre 9 sur 10 ailleurs en ile de
france
voilà donc pour ces réseaux d'éducation
prioritaire il y en a un peu plus d'un
millier en france aujourd'hui grigori
nuisent à vous qui êtes professeur de
français dans un collège de saint denis
vous partager ce constat d'échec
je crois que les mots qui viennent
d'être prononcées tant parlé par
l'enseignant qui a été interrogé que par
que par là la représentante de la fcpe
93 sont représentatifs de ce qui se
passe dans les territoires d'éducation
prioritaires en particulier qui sont des
territoires désormais de relégation la
politique qui est menée actuellement par
par par jean michel blanquer air
pourrait se résumer en une expression
c'est beaucoup de bruit pour rien à
l'image de l' enquête dont vous avez la
consultation des professeurs dont vous
avez parlé dont vous avez parlé à
l'instant qu'est ce qui se passe en fait
dans l'est dans les établissements qui
devraient bénéficier si l'on reprend les
termes de la circulaire savary de qui
définit le laisse que c'est que
l'éducation prioritaire c'est devrait
bénéficier ces établissements d'un
renforcement de l'action éducative
puisque quelqu'un puisqu'elles sont
elles puisque c'est là où ce sont des
territoires où il ya les plus grandes
inégalités sociales or ce qui se passe
c'est qu'on a une égale un sentiment
d'exaspération qui était en train de
grimper qui explose très clairement
c'est dans ces zones
parce que la matérialisation et les
moyens qu'ils devaient suivre
ne sont pas à la hauteur des discours
tenus tout simplement alors il ya eu des
réformes successives en 1990 97 2006
2011 et 2014
line un humain bocage pour essayer
d'améliorer c'est c'est d'abord zones
d'éducation prioritaires qui sont
devenus aujourd'hui un réseau
d'éducation prioritaire qu'est ce qui a
changé finalement par exemple 2014 najat
vallaud belkacem a fait une réforme
elle a parlé de rep et d'auray plus
qu'est ce qui a changé et est ce que les
résultats sont là
en fait ce qu'on peut dire c'est que au
niveau des rep et des raies plus il y a
eu plus de moyens qui ont été mis à
disposition pour les professeurs avec
une va dire une porte et comparative par
rapport à d'autres établissements
au regard des de la cs est en fait du
niveau on va dire économique et social
des familles catégories
socioprofessionnelles
socioprofessionnelles et en fait la
question se pose de savoir si
effectivement les moyens qui sont mis en
place par rapport à ces catégories
socioprofessionnelles correspondent
effectivement aux besoins tant des
enseignants que des élèves dans ses
structures et dans ces conditions
donc c'est sur ces questions qu'on peut
dire que le constat est quand même
mitigé il y a eu des moyens me mais ces
moyens ont-ils et efficace il ya eu
beaucoup de moyens 1,7 milliard d'euros
par an à peu près celle au budget
consacré à ses à ces zones d'éducation
prioritaire nicolas vidal on met
toujours de plus en plus de moyens
finalement pourquoi cet échec selon vous
bah il ya plusieurs candidatures cause à
ça mais c'est vrai que je partage moi je
regarde plus politique qu'on va dire je
suis pas professeur mais ce qu'on voit
on essaie de réfléchir ses mérites mais
revient sans arrêt exactement et puis on
a parlé beaucoup de professeurs de vos
collègues
effectivement dans les manifestations
construit il ya un sentiment
d'ingratitude
je crois un sentiment d'abandon et je
vais vous dire même j'ai l'impression
que vous êtes quand même les pompiers
vous êtes des soldats du feu vous êtes
en première ligne comme d'ailleurs le
personnel hospitalier
donc ça c'est un vrai problème pour
notre république on a un gros gros
problème à ce niveau là après on pourra
parler effectivement des symptômes de
cause des codes me semblent multiples
aussi et on nous prend de débattre mais
je crois que il faudra qu'à un moment
donné
les moyens de me semble effectivement
mal utilisé et je crois à mon sens qu'il
va falloir on en donne et reprendra
profondeur aussi donner peut-être
réengager dans ces territoires la auprès
des publics les plus les plus
paupérisées culturellement sur ces idées
là il va falloir redonner à un moment
donné le une envie d'excellence
peut-être l'excellence tout est relatif
mais peut-être que dans l'enseignement
il va falloir aussi essayer de remettre
en place aussi bien les professeurs que
les élèves aient forcément que du côté
des élèves bien entendu vous aviez
remarqué dans là dessus mais je crois
que c'est à l'école républicaine
ce qu'on appelle la méritocratie c'est à
dire de pouvoir donner la chance
extraire un individu de son corps social
et que l'école abandonnés puissent
l'émanciper pour devenir citoyen c'est
ça qui me paraît moi c'est cette ligne
là qui me paraît extrêmement importante
avec les problèmes que vous connaissez
les uns et des autres et évidemment pour
l'émanciper grégory trizza il faut aussi
que cet élève puisse obtenir de bons
résultats
sur quels facteurs vous mettez vous le
le compte de ces mauvais résultats est
ce que c'est parce qu'à pas assez de
professeurs est ce que la méthode est
bonne la méthode d'enseignement
qu'est ce qu'il ya de plus dans ces
zones d'éducation prioritaire que
l'école traditionnelle si je puis dire
n'a pas alors je dirais qu'il faudrait
presque inversés la question c'est à
dire que qu'est ce qu'il y a en moins
par rapport à ce qui devrait être tout
simplement parce que moi je m'inscris en
faux dans contre l'idée d'abord il faut
il faut reprendre les chiffres qui sont
quand même assez explicite
aujourd'hui vous l'avez souligné tout à
l'heure le budget de l'éducation
prioritaire c'est 1,7 milliard par an il
faut peser ça en regard du budget 2011
de l'éducation nationale qui est de
52,27 milliards
ça signifie qu'on consacre une part
extrêmement faible à l'éducation
prioritaire il ya aujourd'hui 364 réseau
d'éducation plus prioritaires renforcé
en france 730 réseau d'éducation
prioritaire boussois concerne mille
réseau 1
et aujourd'hui on ne distingue plus en
terme d'effectifs de nombre de postes de
moyens réels supplémentaires sur le
terrain
un établissement d'éducation prioritaire
d'un autre établissement et a fait de
même nombre d'enseignants c'est à
renforcer dans certains territoires il
ya il ya des efforts qui sont faits
la réduction par exemple du seuil
nécessaire du nombre d'élèves par classe
mais on voit que ces seuils sont en
train d'exploser c'est le cas dans le
département donc j'ai où j'exerce qu'il
acquit la seine saint denis
on avait des seuils d'élèves par classe
pour permettre justement d'avoir des
groupes réduits qui sont en train en
fait d'exploser puisqu'il y a de moins
en moins de moyens moyens tant humains
et matériels pour pour faire face à ces
inégalités sociales qu on a beaucoup de
mal évidemment à combler puisque les
faits ne suivent pas les discours tenus
les ni ma vocation est maintenant dans
certaines régions on a vu dans ce
reportage il ya aussi le problème de la
violence qui est qui n'arrange pas les
choses
autant pour les professeurs que pour les
élèves avec
christine renom notamment à cette
institutrice qui s'est donné la mort
parce qu'elle n'en pouvait plus est-ce
qu est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
ce malaise dans ces zones spécifiquement
on parle de l'île de france mais il ya
forcément d'autres zones aussi oui en
fait ce qu alors le cas précis je ne le
connais pas particulièrement mais je
crois qu'il est au fond ça a été dit
emblématique de la situation de beaucoup
d'enseignants et de directeur
puisqu'elle était directrice d'école
maternelle qui se retrouve en fait avec
des charges qui ne correspondent pas à
l'information qu'ils ont pu avoir
initialement qui se retrouvent avec des
changements dans les profits dans fait
des élèves qu'ils rencontrent et pour
lesquels ils ne sont pas préparés et de
la même manière on a quand les élèves
rentrent à l'école il se passe ce qu'on
appelle une adaptation avec le contrat
en fête scolaire n'est jamais explicité
et pour certains élèves qui sont très
éloignées de ce que c'est que l'école il
est sans doute nécessaire que ça puisse
s'organiser et que ça puisse se
s'explique cité quand vous dites le
contrat n'est jamais explicité et bien
c'est à dire que quand on rentre à
l'école et bien vous avez des enfants
qui sont parfaitement on va dire éduquer
sur ce que c'est que rentrer à l'école
comme on doit se comporter qui rentre
dans le moule d'eau locaux disons la
culture scolaire en fait et puis vous
avez d'autres parce qu'ils sont d'une
autre culture qui ne connaissent pas
exactement les codes et donc il ya sept
sans doute cette cette prise en compte à
faire dès l'école maternelle et c'est un
gros travail que les enseignants il faut
savoir que les directeurs d'école sont
aussi des enseignants ils n'ont pas
comme dans le secondaire le statut de
chef d'établissement
ce sont des collègues chargés a ralenti
et puis qu'ils ont on va dire une
gratification en quelque sorte pour le
travail rendu mais le travail est très
très important et puis je joue souvent
le rôle d'intermédiaire avec les
familles et je crois que l'exemple de
christine greneau est emblématique parce
qu'elle est au coeur de la complexité de
la situation scolaire actuel et on le
voit les professeurs qui sont dans la
rue depuis de longs mois maintenant avec
cette réforme des retraites et ses
salaires qui est qui et qui reste gelé
et nicolas vidal ce malaise on ressent
ou lui disiez également dans les
professions médecine celle et gilet
jaune aussi qu'ils ont montré une
fracture de la france territoriales est
ce que cette fracture correspond à ces
zones d'éducation prioritaire pas
forcément d'ailleurs on a découvert
aussi l'art du problème qui touche aussi
les ruraux oui il ya une fracture
effectivement parce que moi je trouve
que c'est l'institution m'ont donné une
des autorisations qui se fait parce que
pour les parents qui ont les moyens pour
les parents qui encadrent une émulation
culturel pour les enfants ces enfants là
doit être accompagné en dehors du temps
scolaire il va y avoir une émulation
dans ces quartiers a jugé hélas la
france rurale aussi également vous avez
forcément un espèce de points de
divergence qui va se faire et on va se
retrouver avec des inégalités très forte
dans le monde du travail parce que
qu'est-ce qui va se payer après c'est le
monde du travail
c'est ça qui va payer c'est à dire que
ces enfants on va avoir du retard terme
sur des cultures est que j'ai un chiffre
alors dès que vous avez 20 % des élèves
entrés en 6e ne maîtrise pas les
fondamentaux des mathématiques et du
français on en a parlé on auront-elles
ça pour moi en tant que journaliste
c'est un chiffre absolument effrayant
office de professeurs car autant plus le
comment et vous qui êtes fils de
profondeur et de professeurs
effectivement donc moi c'est vrai que
c'est assez effrayant et je me dis
comment on creuse les inégalités et je
crois que je crois qu'il sera nécessaire
on en donne et de repenser aussi les
fondamentaux l'apprentissage de la
lecture une nouvelle fois je ne mets pas
en cause des professeurs soyons très
clairs sur une herse et montrent que la
situation vous mettez en cause la
méthode
je pense qu'effectivement il ya des cas
très très difficile et très précis que
nous l'avait dit qu'ils sont très
éloignées de l'école mais j'ai toujours
cru mois en l'école républicaine
regardez le bouquin de jacques de
lacretelle silbermann c'est une autre
époque certes mais c'est quelqu'un qui
se fait une passe à société pas ce qui
rend dans une école républicaine et la
méritocratie fait qu'il est émancipé par
cette école républicaine
donc la question est les centrales parce
que ça va poser
de fait la question essentielle de
l'individu dépouillé de toutes sortes de
connaissances a au passage dans le
citoyen et plus largement vers la
démocratie
de quelle société voulons-nous plus tard
et ces problèmes là je crois que si la
france rurale empathie un peu peut-être
moins que les hommes dont on parle
actuellement mais c'est un vrai problème
c'est central et tout part de là à mon
sens on va en parler en tout cas la
france est très mal notée au niveau de
l' ocde puisque c'est le pays le plus
égalitaire écouter cependant malgré des
bases solides et des forces indéniable
le système scolaire français présente
encore des faiblesses structurelles
la france est l'un des pays le plus
inégalitaire des la zone ocde
quant aux résultats puissent à 2018
nous notons en particulier vous l'avez
largement rappelé que le poids des
déterminismes sociaux et économiques
dans la réussite des élèves
ce poids n'augmentent pas dans cette
enquête autrement dit là aussi une
stabilisation mais nous voulons là aussi
un rebond en finir avec le point des
déterminismes en finir avec le poids des
déterminismes est ce que c'est la bonne
voie en tout cas pour en sortir grégory
trizza selon vous
c'était le projet en tout cas initiale
des politiques des politiques
d'éducation prioritaire je ne suis en
revanche pas du tout convaincu que ce
soit le projet du ministre actuel
puisque effectivement à l'heure actuelle
je reprendrai l'idée principale l'école
de la réussite pour tous et toutes les
élèves est en panne
la faute sans doute aux mécaniciens qui
l'a provoquée et à l'heure actuelle le
mécanicien c'est jean michel drucker qui
met tout dans le détroit est d'accord
avec ça on est d'accord sauf qu'il ya en
ce moment une accélération qui est qui
est très qui est très visible dans la
mesure où on jean-michel bancaire est en
train de repenser
peut-être même de les effacer alors
effectivement après la refondation
d'éducation prioritaire donc en
2014-2015 de la belle avait été avait
été créée rep réseau d'éducation
prioritaire et redd + réseau d'éducation
prioritaire renforcer à terme le rapport
qui a été très clairement commandé à
l'inspection générale par le ministre
qui a été remis en novembre et présenté
à l'assemblée nationale en janvier tout
récemment donc en janvier 2020 préconise
très clairement la sanctuarisation
jusqu'en 2022 des établissements rêve
plus et programmes la délabellisation
c'est à dire la disparition d'un cadrage
national pour les actuels
d'établissements d'éducation prioritaire
qui se redonne viendrait donc les
parents pauvres
or ce qui se passe et c'est là aussi un
des grands enjeux de cette future
réforme ducation prioritaire c'est que
pour sans doute inscrire au s'inscrire
aussi politiquement dans les territoires
les ministres programme de déshabiller
des zones d'éducation prioritaire et les
rep pour rhabiller à peu de frais je
dirais la ruralité en changeant
notamment les indicateurs et en cassant
le cadrage national de l'éducation
prioritaire au profit d'une allocation
progressive de moyens qui serait piloté
en termes académique donc c'est vraiment
un changement de paradigme qui est en
train de s'opérer qui est extrêmement
dangereux et qui remet en cause très
clairement l'école de l'émancipation on
en parlait à l'instant dangereux parce
qu'ils auraient moins de moyens ciblées
sur ces zones déjà qui en manquent
c'est ça tout à fait alors une
attractivité qui de toute façon est déjà
en berne mais qui sait ce qui serait
encore qui sera encore en baisse puisque
disparition évidemment des bonifications
en termes de mutation disparition de la
prime pour les voir aller
et donc une à terme une dispute
disparition des labellisations des rep
au profit d'une de la ruralité alors
évidemment il est bien venu de penser à
la ruralité mais c'est également en
réalité bien sûr aussi sans nous occuper
tout à fait alors le mais le problème
c'est que notre notamment pour vous
donner un exemple ce sera à moyens
constants dans la mesure où la prime qui
est versé à l'heure actuelle aux
enseignants aux enseignantes exerçant
d'éducation prioritaire serait reversé
aux nouveaux arrivants s'installant dans
des établissements dits peu attractif
mais qu'en est il des des enseignants
des enseignants qui étaient déjà en
place dans cet établissement c'est la
question qu'on peut poser et l'inhumain
vocal souveraine d'attractivité pour les
professeurs il existe réellement
vous parlez de formation tout à l'heure
est ce qu ils ont les armes finalement
pour pour rentrer dans ce type
d'établissement et ce qu'est une
formation préalable adore honnêtement la
formation s'est senti vraiment l'un des
parents pauvres jeudi l'un parce que la
situation est suffisament suffisamment
complexe pour ne pas cibler la en
laissant l'autre et les professeurs de
façon générale ne sont pas suffisamment
formés ça fait quelques années que je
suis dans la formation et au fur et à
mesure on a une diminution du temps de
formation et on a eu une perte vraiment
de là on va dire d'un des modules qui me
paraissent qui me paraît le plus
important quand on s'adresse à ce genre
de public c'est celui de la psychologie
de l'éducation
c'est à dire celui qui permet de
comprendre les publics avec lesquels on
peut interagir qui permet d'adapter ses
manières d'enseigner et donc cette
formation ils n'existent plus donc pour
quelles raisons pour des raisons de
budget oui enfin je pense je vais
laisser à d'autres mais fred très
simplement on a moins d'heures donc
forcément et on a fait des choix qui
sont la réforme de la formation qui
interroge beaucoup sur le type de
formation et c'est vrai qu'on peut se
poser la même question quelle école
voulons moore à travers la formation des
enseignants que l'on propose alors
essais rediscuter la raison on la
connaît une école pour tous à égalité
pour tous soyez idée des moyens il
et en tout cas des tentatives des
réformes successives pour essayer
d'améliorer les choses mais les
résultats ne sont pas là donc finalement
qu'elle est là quelle est la meilleure
façon d'y arriver
nous nous avons quelques pistes on peut
dire de réflexion en termes de réflexion
les meilleures réponses sur le terrain
on est à la fois sur le terrain et puis
on a plus aussi de distance
quand on prend le temps de réfléchir à
l'intérieur des laboratoires et
différents labos vont proposer des
choses mais un des points importants qui
ressort et à travers les exemples que
vous avez présenté on peut tout à fait
le pointer c'est qu'il ya un manque de
considération tant des enseignants que
des élèves sa vie des enseignants
on peut parler vous avez parlé de
violence entre élèves effectivement le
cas donc c'est qui et oui voilà qui
montre clairement que voilà il a perdu
la vie mais en tout cas il ya aussi une
violence institutionnelle il ya une
violence symbolique aussi qu'ils
apprennent le société à la base c'est un
problème de société mais dans les mêlées
l'école même est une société il faut
aussi la voir en tant que telle est
l'idée d'une approche plus positive en
fait de ce qu'on pourrait faire à
travers les savoirs il ya une approche
les autoritaires je lâche le mot parce
que l'autorité de transit ivité mais est
ce qu'il ne faut pas un retour peut-être
à la rigueur et à l'ordre alors là je
dirai non
j'aurais dû clairement j'ai toujours
très nuancée mais l'autorité à mon avis
c'est pas surtout tels que c'est conçu
par contre si on est dans un processus
qui consiste à poser une autorité à
travers le savoir que l'on cherche à
partager quand on est professeur mais je
parle de la baguette sur le bout des
doigts un danger non non je sais que
c'est pas la bague a déjà parlé de
violence symbolique on peut se retrouver
dans des dépositions autoritaire non je
crois que c'est une prise en
considération complète des personnes
temps des élèves que des enseignants et
il ya je pense un personnel
il ya aussi une grande importance c'est
le chef d'établissement à leur école à
l'école primaire la directrice mais
aussi dans le secondaire le chef
d'établissement
je pense que cette angoisse important
des transformations l'on doit viser là
on va écouter les rapporteurs de la
mission territoire et réussis dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure un peu prône
davantage de souplesse dans ce problème
du traitement des zones d'éducation
prioritaire écouter les oppositions
centre-ville versus quartier métropole
versus périphérie urbain versus rurales
sont dépassées face aux inégalités qui
ne recule pas seule une politique de
priorisation au plus près des besoins
peut répondre à la réalité des
difficultés des élèves dans tous les
territoires
voilà donc prioriser davantage en tout
cas et pour répondre à la réalité des
difficultés gregory thuillard est ce que
vous allez me dire non mais comment
comment est ce qu'on fait d'ailleurs
faut voir prioriser ces zones difficiles
alors c'est très intéressant parce que
les rapports de l'inspection générale
sont souvent des mines d'informations et
son dd
des exemples parfaits de la novlangue
managériale en place dans l'éducation
nationale quand on parle de prioriser
ont fait en fait référence à l'idée de
faire des choix qui sont faites autant
de sacrifices c'est à dire qu'à moyens
contre un dès lors que l'enveloppé
contraintes bien évidemment il faudra
choisir entre dans un air dans un même
établissement avec une dotation horaire
contraintes et souvent d'ailleurs en
baisse de plus dans de plus en plus
chaque année
choisir entre développer des projets
nous permettre permettre des
dédoublements qui qu'ils puissent
alléger les effectifs va en parler dans
la deuxième thématique mans on a cette
priorisation qui est qui en fait une des
diktats de l'institution mais qui ne
fonctionne qui ne veut qui ne peut
fonctionner qu'avec qu'avec des moyens
afférents aujourd'hui de quoi on a
besoin de poser la question de vous
poser la question tout à l'heure il
s'agit pas simplement de crier de crier
aux moyens comme ça de façon un alpage
s'agit de voir de quoi on a besoin
réellement on a dans les établissements
par exemple actuellement aurait plus d
heures de concertation qui peuvent
permettre aux enseignants enseignants de
se retrouver dans des équipes
pluriprofessionnelles parce qu'on parle
souvent des enseignants des enseignantes
mais on parle il faut parler de tous les
personnels dans un établissement dont on
manque d'ailleurs drastiquement dans
certains dans certains territoires la
médecine scolaire les assistantes
sociales les assistants d'éducation les
cpe tous et second degré en tout cas
tous et tous ses différents métiers sont
là pour pour concourir à la réussite est
bien évidemment la disparition de ses
moyens fait que on a de moins en moins
d'adultes qui peuvent encadrer et
accompagner vers la réussite
les élèves
deux façons de façon bénéfique on va
continuer d'en parler bien sûr rester
avec nous on continue ce débat sur
l'état de l'éducation nationale en
france
comment remonter le niveau des élèves
dans le pays dans ces fameuses zones
défavorisées on en parle dans quelques
minutes à tout de suite rester avec nous
[Musique]
l'arrivée de la soul ogier est ce qu'on
peut parler de révolution
techniquement oui on peut parler de
révolution est ce qu'on pourrait pas
réservé sa à des applications bien
précise plutôt que vouloir absolument le
mettre à disposition de tout le monde il
faut avoir en tête pour que pour chaque
génération il faut qu'elle soit
accompagnée d'un kill à l'application
ça veut dire développer une application
qui fait le bout est ce que on a bien
mesuré toute la dépense énergétique de
nouveaux terminaux de nouvelle
implantation de relais le futur de la
cinq cdc des systèmes de communication à
très très très haut débit suffisant
enfin télécharger un film plus vite
qu'est ce que ça va vous apporter les
craintes et c'est par ce manque
d'information est probablement un manque
de collaboration est ce que aujourd'hui
le monde entier a besoin de l'assemblée
le football est richissime et le
football génère beaucoup d'argent donc
génère beaucoup de redistribution pour
les footballeurs des principaux sportif
et donc leur rémunération
mais à côté tous les sportifs et
l'immense majorité des sportifs de haut
niveau qui participent aux jeux
olympiques et participe à des
championnats du monde gagne très mal
leurs vies ne sont absolument pas ni ne
sont pas aidés ne sont pas soutenues et
résultats comme vous l'avez dit 4 sur 10
gagnent moins de 500 euros par mois donc
je pense qu'il faudrait réfléchir sur un
dispositif vraiment plus spécifique
puisque le monde du sport c'est une
spécificité donc peut-être tenté de
rentrer de rentrer dans sa pour pouvoir
mieux accompagner les sportifs de haut
niveau est considérée l'espoir un peu
amateur comme vous l'avez si bien
vialatte et isme ou d'autres sports
comme un métier on parle de jeu pour le
sport on parle de loisirs de pratique de
loisirs vraiment d'amusement et de
métier contraignant de pénibilité pour
le travail et ont donc il serait logique
d'accorder des aides et des soutiens
pour les travailleurs est illogique de
faire de même pour les sportifs puisque
il s'amuse
[Musique]
à
mais oui
[Musique]
pôle it mag la suite avec une line numa
bocage professeur des universités et
spécialiste de l'éducation et grégory
touiza co secrétaire départemental du
syndicat snes fsu de seine saint denis
et nicolas vidal directeur de
publication de putsch médias lors de la
dernière rentrée scolaire la france
comptait un peu plus d'un millier de
réseau d'éducation prioritaire
un système qui coûte cher qui a été mise
en place il ya 40 ans à peu près mais
dont les résultats ne sont pas
satisfaisants
c'est ce qui ressort en tout cas du
dernier rapport de la cour des comptes
publié en 2018 voyez les détails avec
david khalifa alors c'est vrai qu'est ce
que c'est ce sont trois axes un
accompagner les élèves dans leur
apprentissage et dans la construction de
leur parcours scolaire
deux des équipes éducatives forme est
stable et soutenue et 3 un cadre propice
aux apprentissages
sur le papier le ministère de
l'éducation nationale a tenté d'aider
les élèves en difficulté problème les
résultats ne suivent pas et sont même
décevant pour un prix exorbitant 1,6
milliard d'euros selon le dernier
rapport de la cour des comptes
conclusion les zones rep sont remises en
question et du côté du gouvernement on
envisage même de les supprimer les
chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes en français
et en mathématiques par exemple les
résultats sont 20 à 35% moins bons que
dans les autres établissements
l'objectif fixé était de réduire à moins
de 10%
les écarts de niveau entre les élèves en
éducation prioritaire et les autres
l'étiquette éducation prioritaire n'a
donc pas amélioré les performances
scolaires elle peut même avoir un effet
pervers en renforçant la mauvaise
réputation des établissements
d'où la volonté des chefs
d'établissement de sortir de ces zones
la cour des comptes propose elle de
créer des catégories intermédiaires de
collège
ce qui permettrait de prendre en compte
les 70 % d'élèves défavorisés qui ne
font pas partie aujourd'hui de
l'éducation prioritaire
grégory cuisait l'objectif c'était de
réduire à 10 % l'écart entre les
les zones d'éducation classique les
zones d'éducation prioritaires là on
voit qu'on en est loin encore 20 à 30 %
d'écart dans les niveaux c'est ce que
vous constatez également effectivement
baissé ce concept qu'on constate du
moins sûr sur les chiffres 1 qui sont
basés notamment sur les évaluations qui
sont qui sont passés dans les différents
cycles différents étapes de la la
scolarité encore faudrait-il aussi
remettre en cause des évaluations qui
sont passés uniquement sur des parcs
informatiques dont la vétusté est devenu
proverbial mais ça c'est dû à quoi
concrètement vous vous êtes professeur
deux photos français à quoi c'est dû
alors il y a plusieurs facteurs qui
expliquent qui explique ses difficultés
il ya évidemment tous les facteurs qui
sont extérieurs à l'école mais qui
rentre et contre contre lesquels
devaient lutter l'éducation priorité le
manque de soutien de la famille le lait
les classes socioprofessionnelles
défavorisées par exemple le fait que le
capital culturel les enfants même les
enfants arrivent avec des capitaux
qu'une d un capital culturel qui
évidemment insuffisant à l'école
puisqu'ils viennent justement de deux
quartiers populaires des sonorisations
n'ont pas grand chose alors l'école est
justement là pour veiller que je sois là
et j'essaie d'oublier la circulation
pour les extirper une seule condition
est là là là la difficulté c'est que
c'est qu'on est on est très clairement
en deçà des objectifs que s'était fixés
la politique d'éducation prioritaire il
ya 40 ans moi j'insiste un encore une
fois sur sur 7 sur ses difficultés
tant qu'on n'aura pas réellement une
politique d'envergure une politique
ambitieuse parce qu'on parle
effectivement de chiffres lors la cour
des comptes est toujours bien placé mais
depuis ce qu'elle pense avec son porte
monnaie mais il s'avère que le
les moyens on regarde des nécessités des
1000 réseau d'éducation prioritaire sont
largement insuffisants et se sont pas
uniquement quand on parle donc on parle
de moyens financiers et de budget on
parle de moyens horaires aussi de temps
dégagé pour accompagner les élèves vers
la villa vers la réussite de d'effectifs
en baisse de manière à pour avoir des
processus de remédiation vis-à-vis des
élèves qui sont par exemple en
difficultés des sous sols a mené
soutient effectivement des soutiens
alors là on a un dispositif par exemple
qui a été qui a essayé qui a été déversé
d'ailleurs sans aucun cadre légal qui
est depuis deux ans qui s'appelle
devoirs faits qui était un des éléments
des gadgets ministériel qui a été donné
on en voit les résultats qui sont bien
piètre également puisque de toute façon
ces heures sont utilisés pour tout autre
chose et souvent d'ailleurs pour faire
du pour faire du soutien plutôt que de
l'accompagnement de l'accompagnement aux
devoirs tant qu'on n'aura pas repenser
le temps à l'intérieur des
établissements scolaires et donc le
temps forcément par rapport à des moyens
financiers on ne pourra pas solutionné
trouver une solution en tout cas ça
c'est à ces difficultés
li numéro 15 70 % des élèves appartenant
à des familles de catégories populaires
sont aujourd'hui scolarisés hors de
l'éducation prioritaire
là aussi il faudrait réaménager le
système selon vous il fort probablement
et c'est l'un des effets de on va dire
de la labellisation pourrait plus c'est
l'effet pervers en fait on
l'effet favorable si le fait qu'ils
avaient un fléchage en fait pour les
moyens attribués et puis le contrecoup
c'est que il y à une fuite en fait des
des personnes qui seraient les plus
concernés par ce dispositif et qui vont
essayer d'aller de s'inscrire ailleurs
axa madray partir quoi pourquoi ce débat
je pense que c'est pas seulement une
question de répartition ci sont tout une
question aussi de plus on va dire de
rapprochement de compréhension de ce qui
se passe vraiment dans les airs et
peut-être du coup d'une explication
d'une ouverture on parlait tout à
l'heure des lieux de communication et là
c'est pas seulement à l'intérieur de
l'école
mais c'est aussi envers les familles
donc la communauté éducative qui
constitue depuis 89 en fait et qu'elle
continue à 2 malgré on va dire la loi de
2005 qui n'a pas complètement remis en
question la loi de 89 et le socle commun
qui vise justement que tout le monde
puisse puisse l'atteindre constituent la
communauté avec les parents également
alors je vais poser une question qui
n'est pas forcément à créer
très populaire est ce que le niveau a
baissé finalement est ce qu'on dépense
est ce que on entend souvent chez les
parents est ce que le niveau n'est pas
arabe et c'est justement pour essayer de
niveler et avoir des meilleurs résultats
possibles je vous la pose à vous
lindemann aux cages alors le niveau a
baissé en fait les rapports de la cour
des comptes montrent que finalement ils
se sont quand même maintenu les enquêtes
pisa sont à avoir dans le détail c'est à
dire que tous les soirs et bon c'est ce
qu'a dit jean michel djian clair que
pour les accompagner les élèves aussi
qui sont en difficulté en fait compte
tenu de l'aggravation de leur situation
et de la situation familiale on aurait
pu s'attendre à pire en fait et
finalement ils se sont maintenus et donc
ça c'est le premier point
le deuxième point est ce que le niveau
baisse en fait les élèves et surtout les
élèves de ce2 season aux 6-11 des
trésors en fait de deux compétences
extrascolaires parce qu'elles ne sont
pas prises en compte dans les cadres
academy et quand on essaie de les faire
travailler sur d'autres projets eh bien
on a d'autres élèves
alors on va écouter ce qu'on pense tu
ferais je vous ferai réagir là-dessus
nicolas vidal ancien ministre de
l'éducation nationale le vrai problème
aujourd'hui pardon de le dire c'est pas
l'école c'est les familles
si l'éducation dans les familles n'a pas
pressé d enseignement d'enseignement est
impossible voilà point final donc jamais
on a eu des profs aussi bon qu
aujourd'hui on est on a des très bons
profs
en fait le problème c'est les familles à
la base nicolas vidal
moi je me serais en faux avec ça parce
que l'école républicaine ce n'est pas
l'idée que je m'en fais la méritocratie
ce n'est pas l'idée que je m'en fais une
petite observation magali sur
l'indigence caverneuse de la
priorisation l'art n'est vraiment la
start-up nationaux et à la découpe
absolument de service public et moi je
crois que c'est pas une crise une crise
de l'enseignement est une nouvelle fois
je jette pas la pierre aux professeurs
aux enseignants je pense que c'est la
crise d'une nation qui ne veut plus qu'à
prier en horreur 200 seigner s'est tu il
me semble que dans le français et on
prend discuter je pense que le centre de
l'échec scolaire c'est la lecture la
compréhension
si on ne parle pas bien qu'on ne
maîtrise pas bien on vit dans une
société de plus en plus complexes donc
on est forcément rapidement dépassé par
une société professionnellement et une
nouvelle fois
je crois que ce passage-là de l'école on
est pour moi je préfère parler
d'instruction vous savez il y avait
l'éducation l'instruction d'ailleurs mr
nobody voir question l'éducation est à
la maison et l'instruction à l'école ou
à ce que j'ai dans ton du jeu
c'est compliqué parce que je crois
qu'aujourd'hui l'école est en train de
prendre une énorme vague et d'ailleurs
je le donne une petite info bugs bunny
impôts parce qu'on le sait mais en 1932
c'était le ministère de l'instruction
publique et c'est devenu le ministère de
l'éducation nationale
donc je crois qu'il est nécessaire je le
répète on doit avoir un droit à
l'excellence et les fondamentaux que
sont la langue la sémantique le
vocabulaire l'expression devrait être
absolument un effort massif et j'ai pas
l'impression et on parle du socle commun
je crois que c'est et non 20 ans
bruxelles qui avait cessé dix sept mais
là on voit d'ailleurs j'ai lu les sept
points et beaucoup de plaisir à les sept
recommandations de bruxelles
on voit que c'est quand même sur quatre
points le 3 le cadre de saint-leu 6
c'est quand même très managériale l'adie
enseigne la dimension européenne
tous les gens parlent de leurs activités
extrascolaires
mais on veut faire des citoyens les amis
on veut faire des citoyens dans un
premier temps ces gens on a besoin que
ces générations qui vont reconstituer la
france de demain puisse avoir
moi je n'appelle à l'esprit critique au
libre arbitre
c'est ça c'est à mon sens c'est le
travail des enseignants et c'est un
travail passionnant on en a une
civilisation à la cité française a une
culture incroyable avec des textes
incroyable et une dernière anecdote j'ai
rencontré hors berger récemment qui me
paraît besoin sur l'accès à la culture
et je lui disais je pose la question de
savoir si pour un jeune élève et on va
rentrer dans le dur du sujet je vais
être un peu polémique s'il était
préférable fille tenant d'aller voir une
pièce de théâtre où l'iran livrent avec
l'accompagnement scolaire avec
l'accompagnement du professeur de
l'enseignant pour pour tous mondiale
nickelés ou été préférable d'aller voir
un concert d'une artiste bien au sec est
une usine à cash elle m'a dit ne faut
pas hiérarchiser les esthétiques non on
ne sait au moment de donner un socle qui
doit être une sphère de l'éducation
nationale
mais le problème est que la limite est
extrêmement de tangente
c'est ça et je crois qu'effectivement
vous l'avez dit vous avez posé la
question par novagali
je crois que les institutions l'état
dans lequel est en train d'essayer de
faire un nivellement par le bas en nous
expliquant avec cette novlangue
d'ailleurs vous m'avez voler le mot
d'humour était une novlangue qui à mon
avis cachent des problèmes qui sont déjà
là et qui vont forcément se renforcer
parce qu'on est dans une ghettoïsation
culturel intellectuel de société qui a
vraiment un mauvais un très très mauvais
signal pour une démocratie comme être
dans un pays comme la france mais
effectivement selon une étude plus d'un
jeune sur 2 cumulé les moins hors
grandes métropoles moins d'informations
moins de possibilités culturelles
académique et professionnel -2 de role
models également moins d'activités
extrascolaires moins de mobilité
conclusion - dont on le voit à l'écran
moins de chances de se réaliser et
d'accomplir sa vie c'est à un contexte
général grégory suis à vous constatez ce
problème d'environnement justement de
ces enfants dans ces zones d'éducation
prioritaire je crois que je crois que
dans les zones d'éducation prioritaire
on a aussi le reflet de la tension
sociale en cours vous le disiez tout à
l'heure par rapport aux mouvements
sociaux qu'on connaît depuis maintenant
depuis maintenant plus d'un an et demi
on a le reflet d'un mouvement social est
dû
dureté social en cours il ne faut pas
penser contrairement souvent aux
éléments de langage ministériel qu'un
établissement scolaire s'est il doit
être sanctuarisé un établissement
scolaire doit rester ouvert justement
sur le territoire c'est ce qu'on entend
souvent il faut sanctuariser évidemment
le milieu scolaire ex le mans sanctuary
sanctuarisées à l'heure actuelle en
seine saint denis ça consiste pour les
collectivités territoriales par exemple
responsabilité à mettre de la
vidéosurveillance partout à relever les
grilles des établissements au lieu de
renforcer les équipes d'accompagnement
de prévention c'est exactement ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui ce dont se fait un peu
des deux noms vous pensez qu'il faut pas
du tout de surveillance mois on sent que
60 enseignants en tant qu'enseignant je
suis forcément du côté de la prévention
de l'accompagnement des des élèves des
adolescents et des jeunes adultes
enfin on regardera aussi qu'on a vu ça
aussi il faut pouvoir les éviter
bien sûr bien sûr mais ils sont ils sont
malheureusement et eon
certains de certains territoires en
connaissent en connaissent assez souvent
ils sont le reflet aussi d'une tension
sociale que n'arrive plus justement à
corriger à gommer à gommer vous la
sentez vous cette tension sociale et
quand est ce que vous la gérez anton
professeur alors on l'a on la ressent on
la ressent au quotidien par des
difficultés qui se trouvent dans
l'intérieur des établissements en termes
de climat scolaire aux et à l'extérieur
des établissements aussi il ne faut pas
évidemment cacher les réalités
difficiles tous connaissent que
connaissent les quartiers populaires
avec des difficultés aux abords des
établissements des affrontements que
vous connais aussi dans la vie d'un
excellent mix restaurer aux scolaires
qui sont experts scolaire mais qui ont
une influence effectivement sur sur
l'école pour autant on ne trouvera pas
de solution si l'on fait de le de
l'école un territoire qui est à côté des
quartiers dans lesquels elle s'inscrit
il faut au contraire évidemment
développer le jeu justement la relation
de l'ensemble de la communauté éducative
dialoguer avec les parents dialoguer
avec les différents professionnels mais
ce n'est pas une c'est pas étonnant
qu'on est con et ce genre de ce genre de
tensions les politiques actuelles aussi
vide par exemple de leurs moyens de
leurs moyens humains et les antennes
jeunesse la disparition de certains
contrats qui était certes précaire mais
qui existait dans l'est dans les
quartiers populaires sont cons les
interlocuteurs les interlocutrices dans
les services publics ne sont plus là en
clair et pour résumer pour résumer les
choses je pense que il y à une
organisation concertée d'une destruction
du service public d'éducation comme on
peut avoir dans d'autres services
publics aussi elle est accompagnée n'at
on dit souvent les parents ont
ne veulent plus inscrire leurs enfants
dans les établissements de 16h dans les
secteurs sauf on observe que pour
comment comment comment on perds ton ont
fait dysfonctionné un service public
pour faire rentrer en fait le loup dans
la bergerie à savoir la privatisation
rampante une intervention de certaines
associations d'orientation par exemple à
capitaux privés de fondations privées
systématiquement faire dysfonctionné un
service public is a permis ensuite de
faire rentrer l'idéologie de la start up
nation
on a en place à l'heure actuelle il est
inhumain blocage vous avez prononcé un
mot qui est intéressant les parents est
ce que les parents sont là est-ce que
vous ce que les professeurs se sentent
suffisamment épaules et surtout dans ces
zones difficiles ou pas alors d'un ça
compte aussi que le départ absolument
les parents y sont ils sont vraiment
partie prenante et dans votre question
et c'est que des enseignants sont
accompagnés par les parents je dirais
que on a plutôt tendance à voir qui a
besoin d'éléments de parentalité en fait
un les parents eux mêmes et c'est ce qui
a été dit un de jeudi à la société
actuelle est telle qu'ils sont de plus
en plus démunis eux mêmes et ça se
ressent sur sur les élèves
et forcément quand il entre à l'école il
entre avec toutes ces tensions et le
travail des enseignants pour relier
faire le lien avec des parents n'est pas
seulement que de leur fait
la réduction de ce qu'on appelle un
pauvre on dans les textes il est
question à l'heure actuelle d'une école
inclusive d'une société inclusive mais
le lin on va dire que il y a une
interprétation qui ne renvoient pas
exactement ce que devrait être
l'inclusion scolaire c'est à dire que on
vous dit que ben il faut faire entrer il
faut inclure il faut intégrer or
vraiment dans l'airé fait serment du
temps on savait rien
ça donne du temps pour 7 mars et
demandent du temps c'est pas seulement
recevoir à ça peut être tout simplement
dans une participation collective de ce
qui se fait déjà dans ce qui serait déjà
et là dessus il ya des actions qui se
font mais qui ne remontent pas on n'est
pas toujours au courant de ce que les
professeurs ou dans certaines structures
parviennent à faire pour que le climat
scolaire change le climat scolaire
s'améliore et que effectivement on voit
des résultats avant aussi dans ce sens
alors je voulais juste dire quand même
quelque chose par rapport à
l'instruction et à l'éducation
c'est tant que c'est encore en
discussion et je voudrais juste en mieux
et je voudrais ramener un psychologue
français qui à mon avis est très
important ces vallons et henri wallon a
dit on ne peut pas scindé l'esprit d'un
individu en deux c'est à dire que
l'élève qui vient à l'école
il arrive avec tout ce qu'il est en tant
que personne et la difficulté ça c'est
une vraie difficulté pour l'enseignant
c'est de le prendre tel qu'il est pour
effectivement les dea dans le
développement et dans la maîtrise des
savoirs et leurs structures aussi
connaissent à briser tout à fait est
bien de savoir donc l'élever
un mot important
on a parlé cette start up nation de
privatisation parce que la réalité
aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'on veut faire des citoyens
on va en faire des consommateurs soyons
très clairs avec une corne une europe et
la mondialisation la globalisation donc
on est là dedans et puis une observation
je crois qu'il ya une incohérence avec
je crois que je sais pas comment l'état
pourrait faire mais quand vous avez tant
de mainstream
quand vous avez tant de clips temps de
trucs totalement débile dans
l'abrutissement des réseaux sociaux
réseaux sociaux je parle de tous les
séries mad men three oui il arrive aussi
aux smartphones pierre jourde je vous
rappelle écrivain qui a été sabrée
plaire qu'aux allemands s commune et de
la communauté littéraire disait que la
télé est une arme de destruction massive
on en haut mais il faut avoir une
cohérence on peut pas abrutir les gamins
et de et vous demander à vous derrière
de récupérer et de se trouver à regarder
à l'été nous quand vous étiez jeune bien
entendu elle a bien entendu mais il me
semble que très jeune je me suis farci
et ce qui doit naître il ya madame
bovary ou des who ou zola et très
sincèrement ça a été compliqué c'était
presque coercitif mais très sincèrement
aujourd'hui au combien j'apprécie que
les enseignants mais fait lire ça et mes
traîner un peu sur ces textes là parce
qu'ils étaient exigeants ça m'a gonflé
quand je fais mais très sincèrement
couvre les salles des verrous les clés
une certaine exigence peut-être qu'il ya
qui a disparu ou par un grégory trizza
c'est vrai que les réseaux sociaux
maintenant les jeunes sont beaucoup sur
ces réseaux sociaux on les a beaucoup
incriminés dans l'échec scolaire c'est
le cas selon vous pas alors ils
participent ils participent et ça leur
ouvre l'esprit aussi alors c'est
effectivement une forme d'ouverture il
faut pas oublier que sur le sur les
réseaux sociaux on peut avoir aussi des
éléments de contestation
d'information si c'est ça leur permet
une ouverture d'esprit après comme pour
tout média comme pour tout médium il
faut une éducation qui passe aussi par
l'école et faut pas interdire tout
simplement les téléphones dans les
enceintes scolaires se lancer le cas
dans les années lycée le sélectif c'est
le sait le texte en ça c'était aussi un
peu une mesure quand même cosmétiques je
dirais parce que dans les faits c'était
déjà le cas dans les règlements
intérieurs des établissements dont qui
avait pas besoin de faire une loi là
dessus mais c'est pas respectée dans
l'est dans les faits si on le fait en
tout cas dans les établissements pour
pourront parcourir un certain nombre de
départs canon j'exerce c'est plutôt
respecté un après je moi je concours à
l'idée qu' il y à une organisation très
clair delà de la relégation sur un plan
culturel aussi de ces territoires
il faut préserver l'entregent des
classes des classes favorisées et
conserver une forme d'une forme de
relégation qui fait que notamment avec
des dés dispositif de tri social comme
on a connu avec parcours super la suite
la suite du lycée on voit bien on voit
très bien notamment par le par la
transformation d'un cadrage national du
baccalauréat en cadrage locales par
exemple et bien rapports d'inspection
générale le au soccer même deux
du ministère qui vient d'étriller la
réforme bancaire du lycée et notamment
les épreuves de les épreuves communes de
ce contrôle continu en renvoyant
systématiquement au local en renvoyant
systématiquement à l'autonomie des
établissements plutôt qu'à un cadrage
national fort on fragmente autorités
davantage au rectorat
le but de la réforme on va justement
écouter jean michel blanquer
qui a dit que finalement le niveau des
élèves est en train de remonter
jean michel blanckaert qui a préconisé
davantage de classes de dédoublements de
classes écoutez le le chemin que nous
avons pris depuis deux ans c'est celui
de réussir quelque chose qui n'a jamais
été réussi aucun pays au monde c'est à
dire d'en finir avec les écarts de
résultats qu'on constate entre les
territoires les plus défavorisés et le
reste du pays
nicolas villa est très optimiste un jean
michel blanquer en tout cas yvon ils
vont y arriver les dédoublements de
classe c'est une bonne idée
vous en conviendrez que matt rand yambi
face au ministre très sincèrement que le
grand bien lui fasse moi je suis plutôt
henri troyat knapp chatte
mais concrètement moi j'y crois pas je
vais j'ai développé cette idée là
aujourd'hui et rebondir aussi parce
qu'il ya une vraie inégalité wind in
guitare isme sur des gens aujourd'hui on
le sait des parents qui sont en train de
semer leurs enfants de faire toute une
série de menus de pour la carte mère de
faire admettre leurs enfants dans des
collèges d'un délit c'est qu'ils sont
mieux réputé donc on est totalement le
site à l'américaine où les gens qui
peuvent qui ont les moyens et les appuis
par son existant car voilà voilà et ça
et une dernière chose quand je vois
certains politiques où je ne citerai pas
l'école privée qui est près de chez nous
de la rédaction je les vois mettre leurs
enfants alors que les plateaux ils nous
promettent autre chose l'égalitarisme
habitiez sociale je trouve que c'est une
grande escroquerie intellectuelle et que
là on est quand même
le club républicaine est quand même la
mixité c'est peut-être le mot clé vous
avez raison que la vida la mixité est ce
qu'elle est suffisamment présente dans
les établissements est ce que finalement
faire des zones d'éducation prioritaire
c'est pas forcément une bonne idée il
vaudrait peut-être mieux revenir un des
écoles où il ya tous les niveaux tout
les touffes tous les types d'élèves
alors la mixité effectivement des
publics qui est une des thunes des
devrait être en tout cas un des grands
objectifs de l'éducation nationale
puisque la secousse que ce que ce que
les différentes politiques ont créé ce
sont des territoires de plus en plus
reléguée à tel point que les élèves
matérialise eux mêmes et elles mêmes
dans leurs discours gates a fait ce qui
est bien c'est pas forcément donc la
mixité est très très clairement une
objectif qui doit être celui de
l'éducation nationale moi je je suis
toujours j'ai toujours un sourire mais
un peu narquois lorsque j'entends notre
notre ministre puisqu'il est toujours
prêt pour tout prêt pour la
revalorisation des enseignants et
enseignantes prêt pour la réussite de
tous les élèves
mais lorsqu'on organise des évaluations
par exemple qui en fait seront la vue
uniquement pour valider sa politique
dans quelques années on peut douter
quand même venu voir à remonter c'est
faux alors il dit le niveau à remonter
pour se féliciter pour se délivrer un
autosatisfecit à lui-même et à ses
services
en réalité tant qu'on n'aura pas
redéfini et en compte en tant qu on met
gautherat sur les publics les plus
fragiles parce qu'on parle des zones
d'éducation prioritaire il faut parler
aussi de tous ces publics qu on sabre
dans les différentes politiques ont
parlé de l'école inclusive tout à
l'heure alors on fait des grands
discours sur l'école inclusive sur les
éduque sur les élèves en situation de
handicap par exemple mais en seine saint
denis où j'exerce on a diminué
systématiquement les horaires par
exemple des unités locales
d'accompagnement des élèves en situation
de handicap les ulis on atomisent les
les différentes unités qui accueille des
élèves les
nouvellement arrivés en france comme des
ipo 2 a par exemple ces dispositifs qui
permettent justement de procéder à une
inclusion ensuite donc on est en train
de sabrer le service public d'éducation
tout en tenant des grands discours sur
le niveau monte
on va continuer évidemment d'en parler
dans nos prochains magazine
évidemment on va passer à notre sondage
en ligne et vos réactions sur les
réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
et on a posé la question aux auditeurs
terre tu es france pensez-vous que le
niveau scolaire a baissé ces dix
dernières années vous voyez le résultat
est la réponse est oui à 93% non à 7%
avec quelques réactions que l'on va
découvrir à l'écran on rend coupable les
parents combien de femmes peuvent rester
à la maison afin de s'occuper des
enfants et surtout pour le temps des
devoirs bien sûr ça c'est un problème
récurrent j'imagine grégory couiza de
pouvoir soutenir les élèves à la maison
un changement de société donc la
meilleure des choses à faire c'est
revenir à l'enseignement des années 70
cinq jours de cours par semaine et
interdiction de smartphones on en a
parlé donc peut-être un peu plus de de
rigueur et non pas d' autoritarisme
l'inhumain vos cases mais rssi beaucoup
merci d'avoir accepté de débattre sur ce
plateau c'est la fin de deux pôles it
mag est resté avec nous
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
c'est le sentiment que que vous avez eue
vous aussi ce besoin d'autonomie
oui complètement besoin d'autonomie
besoin de retourner à des choses plus
essentielles en fait est vraiment de
sentir qu'on n'est pas forcément un
poids pour la planète
il ya une idée derrière il ya une
philosophie aussi qu'on avait